okay hi everyone welcome to another
episode of uh science and technology q a
for kids and others and i see that there
are a bunch of questions
uh left over from last time
oh boy here's a weird one if you
couldn't be a human
what animal would you want to be and why
what non-human non-alien species is
capable of doing smart
impactful things oh it's an interesting
question
so i mean the one question is
what do animals what are animals
actually other than humans actually
capable of
do we know uh you know is there a great
civilization that has been built by
whales but we just don't know it
one of the questions that uh is always a
challenging one
is we have a certain way of thinking
about things uh
we know what we humans do but the
question is can we
if if we're trying to identify uh the
sort of the
the the meaning and and structure of
something built by non-humans
what can we identify you know even for
us humans it's pretty challenging
if you go back and look at
archaeological remains
you say you know you look at stonehenge
bunch of you know this
circle of stones that's uh that's in
england where you look at
cave paintings um from i don't know 40
000 years ago or something
and you say what or even much longer ago
than that
uh what are these things what were they
supposed to represent
are they something significant that's
indicative of some
sophisticated uh thinking and
civilization and so on
or are they just let's say it's a cave
painting are they just sort of
places where people randomly stuck their
hands on the side of the cave after
after they coated them in some kind of
paint-like substance
it's tough to know unless we have kind
of a
a direct sort of historical thread that
traces us back
to whatever it is that we see in these
archaeological remains
it's it's very hard for us to know how
does this relate to something that we
think of as important
and civilization related today
and so you know that poses a big problem
when it comes to
interpreting uh things for other
critters
um it's like uh when we see the ants
building this very elaborate
uh you know ant hill or something uh to
what extent is that
a a thing that is like uh us
you know building a cathedral or
whatever and to what extent is it
something
quite different and much simpler very
hard to know
um i think that uh we humans
are we have one very important
characteristic which
doesn't seem to be shared at least
not too much by other kinds of critters
which is this ability to communicate
abstract ideas
using language to be able to to take
kind of the things we're thinking about
and represent them abstractly
and then be able to communicate them to
to other humans
and that seems to be the the sort of
critical capability
that's allowed us over the course of of
you know hundreds thousands of
generations
to build up sort of all the the
sophistication that we
that we have now and that doesn't
kind of probably seem to happen in other
animals it's really hard to know
let's take wales as an example you know
it's been known for a long time that
that wales
uh have these whale songs that they
communicate uh
uh through sound and water and um
uh one feature of um of sound
transmission in water
is that in the deep ocean that's very
very still sound can get transmitted a
long way
thousands of miles so a whale that's
sort of on one side of the pacific
can be having its conversation with a
whale
on the other side of the pacific uh and
um you know you can
you can get some evidence i think of
sort of communication
that happens over in large populations
over over long distances like that
what does this communication mean we
have no idea
uh is it something that uh seems a bit
more like uh
the whale just sort of whistling to
itself or or like
some kind of chirping bird that's just
like oh i'm i'm uh
i'm happy today i'm going to chirp and
doesn't really mean anything in our
usual sense of meaning
or is it something that is representing
the you know the homeric
poems of the whales being communicated
uh you know in an oral tradition one
whale to the next we don't really know
so so if you ask um uh what
um in in what species is it possible can
we imagine sort of building up something
that might be important sort of for the
for the history of the species or the
history of
uh of of of life in general we don't
really know
one of the things that sort of a a um an
issue for
for other species is that uh
you know we humans have have got this
whole sort of ability you know we've got
our hands we make things and we've made
machines that make more things and so on
and we can have a built environment that
is seems pretty sophisticated
of course there are plenty of other uh
creatures
that make built environments from
termites to beavers to whatever else
they just don't seem to us kind of maybe
as sophisticated as ours
but you know it's really hard to tell
sometimes there's this little fish
this is a little puffer fish thing i
think it's it's found in
off japan that goes and it spends you
know a couple of weeks and it makes this
incredibly elaborate
mandala like pattern in the sand which
it then proceeds to destroy
i think it's some kind of mating display
type thing but you know you look at this
thing and it looks
kind of like an elaborate piece of human
artwork
kind of construction is it significant
or is it just the sort of the the reflex
actions of the little puffer fish with
this little circuit of
you know a thousand neurons that is
producing this particular pattern
it's not really clear i mean if you ask
if you take that logic and you just say
well if you could identify it
as being something produced by some
collection of neurons
and you could see how it gets produced
then it can't be significant
but obviously one day we'll be able to
to get data from the hundred billion
neurons that are in our brains and we'll
be able to see that
yes the sentence that i'm saying is the
result of
some collection of electrical signals in
our neurons that are eventually building
up to
to make the sentence and the fact that
we can identify that
as a in a sort of mechanistic way i
don't think really detracts
from whatever the significance of of the
thing that's being said is
now you know one thing that's come out
of a lot of science that i've done
is you might say well gosh if we think
of brains as being a bit like computers
these other critters must have computers
and brains that are somehow
fundamentally less capable than ours
this turns out to be almost certainly
not the case
it's it's once you reach a certain
threshold
it's always possible in principle at
least to program
the thing you have to do whatever
anything else can do
so in other words in some sense it's
like saying
in principle there's a way to you know
train a dog
to do all these very elaborate things um
the
the the fundamental sort of brain
material of the dog
should we think be no less
computationally
capable than the sort of brain material
of us humans
now there are issues like for example
the i o system the input output system
of the dog
is very different from ours you know for
example its input
you know it uses its nose to smell
things a lot we
are not you know primarily were
primarily vision
and sound based uh uh critters
and um in terms of the the sort of the
output
uh you know you don't you don't you
don't get to make
fine objects uh with kind of typical dog
paws and so on
an interesting question of course is
that most of the things we make we don't
make with our own hands anymore
we make them through a chain of
technology that maybe starts with
something from our hands
but is you know far removed from that so
a question that you can ask is well what
if we did the same thing for the dogs
and cats and
and whatever else what if we just had
you know some device
that they could take what they can
actually directly do you know
uh it's like like you know people often
worry about
um having user interfaces for touch
display where you just like
push your finger here push your finger
there rather than
the finer control that might exist in
other cases okay so you've got the
corresponding thing
you put your pore here you put your poor
there how does it how does it work what
can it do
and you know the question of what the
dog interface looks like
and how that relates to the human user
interface this
so-called um human interface design
would become sort of canine interface
design or whatever
how that really would work it's not
completely clear and and what you might
be able to
get uh the dog to create
with its canine interface so to speak
not completely clear
uh you know a couple of issues that come
up it's like it might create this very
elaborate
pattern of things and it might look to
us completely random
what would we conclude then will we
conclude that the dog was just putting
random stuff down
or will we conclude that it had some
profound meaning to the dog
we just don't know what that profound
meaning is and if we say
well it couldn't be have any profound
meaning it's just sort of a random
pattern
well go look at early cave paintings
where they're just kind of
a collection of handprints in different
places are those significant are they
not significant
we just don't really know and uh
the you know the challenge for
for sort of knowing what's going on
inside
uh you know how uh is is it the case
that
but for the fact that there isn't a
chain of automation that allows you to
build
and store different kinds of things
there could perfectly well be a cat
civilization
um we don't really know if
and were there to be such a thing would
it be
bizarrely and alienally different from
anything that we know about we don't
really know
uh the you might say well at least these
these animals are in the same
environment basic
you know natural environment that we
humans are in
um but their experience of it
their senses may be sufficiently
different that their experience of it
may be bizarrely different
and it may be that the kinds of things
let's imagine that
that they were able to produce some kind
of symbolic language
the kinds of words they might have the
kinds of descriptions they might give of
things
might be utterly and bizarrely different
from ours
i mean for instance imagine you know we
have a lot of words that describe visual
scenes for things
but imagine you were primarily sensing
things by smell
there's a probably a whole other lexicon
a whole other
sort of dictionary of different possible
ways oh that's a
that's a smell that has you know a which
we can't really describe with our words
that has sort of a
a round bit on one side and it's pointy
on the other side and it's got some kind
of
flow that looks like this and we can't
really describe it with the words that
we have
because that's not the sensory
experience that we humans have
same kind of thing for aquatic animals
you can certainly imagine there's all
kinds of information about
uh the the flow of fluids the flow of
water
oh you know we might as as people who
know about uh
fluid mechanics and physics say oh
that's a vortex
there that's a a a vortex street
that's a a certain kind of uh flow but
but if you're a dolphin or something
which can uh feel the pressure of water
you know all over your your skin you
might have um
uh all kinds of other elaborate
descriptions of fluid dynamics
that we have no idea about and that we
in our normal experience we're just like
it just looks like it's water
um not oh it's water with this
particular velocity field
that puts this particular pressure on
that one's fin when it when one does
this or that
so it's it's hard to extrapolate these
things and uh
the question of um the question that was
originally asked um
uh what kind of animal would i like to
be
if i wasn't a human i think that's a
very hard thing to answer in in a
in some theory of reincarnation if one's
reborn as a dot dot dot
um i have to say i i um
some at some point i was i was thinking
that there are creatures like uh
uh the nautilus it's a it's a type of of
uh cephalopod
that has uh is is known to have a very
peaceful life or you think it has a very
peaceful life it just goes
it just slowly goes up and down uh in
water
every day and um somehow these these
things where
there's the idea that some particular
kind of critter has a a very peaceful
life
then you discover how does it eat and
then you discover
actually it has a very very peaceful
life until it sees a piece of prey
and then suddenly it turns itself into
something else and it it uh
you know lashes out and gets that piece
of prayer and eats it so
i don't really know i i don't have a i
don't um
i think i'm i'm uh i'm i'm pretty okay
just uh doing the human thing
so i i don't have a great answer to that
let's see i have um
um a lot of questions here
oh there's a question just came in from
jr what technology is necessary for us
humans to be able to provide an
evolutionary update
to any of our sensory organs
yeah i think the most immediate one of
those is for vision
um when our eyes
are sensitive to visible light
visible light light is an
electromagnetic wave
and it's visible light is an
electromagnetic wave of a certain range
of frequencies around a trillion
cycles per second and um
the visible light goes from
uh red at low frequencies
to blue at high frequencies but you can
go beyond those frequencies you can go
into the infrared
or into the ultraviolet which correspond
to
lower frequencies of electromagnetic
radiation or higher frequencies of
electromagnetic radiation
so for example when an object is hot it
will
emit lots of infrared radiation
as it gets hotter and hotter it will
eventually glow and you'll see that as
visible
light you make it even hotter it will go
from red hot
to white hot to blue hot as it
kind of produces higher and higher
frequency electromagnetic radiation
but so if only you could see
in the infrared you would be able to see
oh that thing is hot
even though it isn't yet glowing red hot
it's not hot enough to glow red hot but
you'll be able to see that it's hot
and um so as a sort of a question how
you do that well there certainly exists
uh cameras that are very much like
the standard cameras that we use on our
computers and everything else today and
our phones and so on
today the the sensors just a little tiny
bit different and they can see into the
infrared
in fact even the sensors that we
actually have on our
on our phones and things can see a
little bit into the ultraviolet usually
and usually in order not to confuse the
human users of phones
there they have filters so that you're
they're not sensing the ultraviolet
light
that you see in a room so they're only
sensing the visible light which is what
we see with our eyes um but
they're only showing us the the result
of the visible light but they're
actually sensing
some things that are into the uh the
ultraviolet and sometimes also i think a
little bit into the infrared
um and they're just being sort of uh uh
kind of
constrained in order to not confuse the
human users
but so if you say let's actually have
sensors that can
detect things outside of the visible
range um
then the next question is okay so how
should you show that to us humans
i've wondered about this from time to
time what's the best way
if you could annotate our visual field
if you were using
augmented reality so that you're
projecting
uh sort of additional elements in in the
image
let's say for example a typical method
has a little tiny projector
that is projecting uh directly onto your
retina
so it's kind of it's it will be for
example typically scanning very fast
a very low power laser that would be uh
sort of writing data onto your retina
or it might be something where you
actually have some something which is
forming an image
um that uh your glasses have sort of
optics that let you see at a distance
but the end result the sort of the the
concept augmented reality
is that you can get to superimpose on
your
uh standard visual field additional
information
so for example that additional
information i've always wanted this
might be something that will be a little
sort of caption that says okay you're
you're in a
room with a lot of people you know let's
have a caption
that um uh that can point to each person
and say
what the last time you had an
interaction with that person is by using
face recognition and looking up data
and so on i have to say i'm not sure
quite why
we haven't had more uh
artificial augmented reality um now that
uh we're all using video conferencing
all the time
um i don't see that very often i suppose
i suppose it
in a sense we already have that because
you'll see an icon you know
you'll see an array of pictures of
people and each one will have a name
underneath
um but in any case the the sort of the
concept of augmented reality
is just in your regular kind of looking
around at things
you have some annotation of the visual
field that tells you additional things
about what you're seeing
so what if you also have a camera
that is able to see into the infrared
and into the ultraviolet
what should it do to annotate your
visual scene
well clearly if there's a thing that's
hot but you don't know it it might be
like don't touch that thing you know
warning warning this thing
that this thing is hot and i can tell
that because i can see it in the
infrared
but for example putting an overlay of
color of some other
you know representing the infrared
colors of a particular thing that's a
possibility
might be pretty confusing to us humans
at least for a time
um i think that uh but by the way i mean
we have examples of this
already uh pretty commonly used like
like um
uh cars that have a head-up display
that um sometimes called i don't know
you know for looking for animals in the
road
because animals uh like mammals
are warm-blooded they are typically
hotter
than their environment and so in the
infrared
they're very obvious and so that means
if you have a camera in your car
that is an infrared camera it can
pretty dramatically detect you know a
deer running across the road or
something
um and uh in in cars it's not uncommon
to have some
sort of a head-up display that will
project onto the windshield
something where you'll typically have
you know this white outline
of this hot uh animal and that's that's
an example of sort of seeing in the
infrared
but um sort of what if one had that
on an everyday basis for everything one
was looking at and one's visual scene
was always being annotated with
information about
infrared or ultraviolet pieces i'm not
quite sure what the best way to do that
is
um and but that's a place where we could
imagine sort of augmenting
standard human sensory data now there's
a little bit more you can do with that
uh when we look at a a thing like i
don't know
um oh some some piece of chocolate or
something
we might just see it as a piece of
chocolate that's this sort of brownish
color or whatever else
but actually if you were able to look at
it
uh with precisely enough with with
enough kind of
distinction about exactly what
what light is being absorbed and trap
and uh reflected by the chocolate you
could actually get a lot more
information about the chocolate
so there's a idea it's called usually
hyperspectral imaging
and um the the notion is this uh
we identify we when we look at
when we look at something we say oh that
thing is red that thing is blue whatever
else
but in reality any object has a whole
distribution of different wavelengths
different frequencies of light
that it will absorb and reflect and
our eyes uh just are sensitive to sort
of
three buckets of uh kind of
frequency spectrum red green blue
so for us every color is made up of just
a combination of a certain amount of red
a certain amount of green a certain
amount of blue
but in in reality every object
is generating is reflecting for example
light
that has a whole distribution of
different frequencies so it may be
uh it may instead of just being oh it's
just red um
it's it's a whole distribution that has
some piece of red a piece of yellow et
cetera et cetera et cetera
and that kind of distribution of of how
much light
exists at different frequencies that
there's a
any any material has a certain
characteristic
pattern of what that distribution is for
us
we just say how much red how much green
how much blue is in it and we just say
it's that color
but in reality there's much more
information there's there's the whole
information about the whole spectrum of
different
amounts of amounts of electromagnetic
radiation at different frequencies
and so there are some devices that exist
today
that do some amount of hyperspectral
imaging well at least
uh that they can work out the spectrum
of the light
and so for example there's one that will
tell you you know the fat content in
your piece of chocolate based on that
um and you can do things where you say
uh this
um uh this particular
uh piece of fruit is uh is ripe
even though you can't necessarily see
that invisible light um you can tell
from the way that uh from from this kind
of spectrum
you can tell that information so
hyperspectral imaging is another
thing that sort of augments the human
ability to perceive what's going on
exactly how you should present that
information is not so clear
for example it might be oh um you know
you could annotate what kind of material
this object is you know
you pick up a rock it's like well what
kind of rock is this
well uh with with hyperspectral imaging
it may be very easy to tell what kind of
rock it is
and it's like uh and you could have
something that's sort of a little
caption
in your augmented reality system that
tells you that but
you know the question of how you feed
enough information
into us humans in the right way it's
kind of a
user interface problem of how do we
augment
our even if we we have the the the
sensors
to get us a lot more information how do
we present that in a way that we'll
understand
you know it's a good question if we
routinely
had some sort of overlay of of different
kinds of colors
that represented you know the whole
hyperspectral
story of what what our images were
looking like how quickly would we get
used to being able to use that
information
and how confusing would it be to us and
so on not sure i know the answer to that
i mean the the the we don't really
yet have experience even with augmented
reality we don't know what will happen
um when there finally is fairly routine
augmented reality what will the world be
like
i mean will we be you know will we might
leave sort of visual post-it notes for
us in different places if our
augmented reality system can recognize
oh
uh you know i'm walking back into the
same room that i was in before
oh in this room i left myself a um
uh you know a post-it note a virtual
post-it note that said this or that
where it might you might walk back into
the same room and you know it has a
bookshelf in it
and your uh augmented reality system
might immediately recognize
oh those books are slightly different
than they were uh
two months ago when you last walked into
this room there are books that have been
taken out in this place that place that
place a kind of
visual diff of of what the um what the
room looks like now compared to what the
room looked like before
and that's another example of kind of
augmenting our human senses
because we might say oh something looks
different about this room but we'd be
very unlikely to be able to give
that precise stiff information but
that's something we can imagine doing
uh without using any kind of different
input than just the visible light image
of things
but that's just an additional piece that
we can imagine there
now i mean there are there are many
other kinds of
um sensors that we can imagine using for
example there are ones that
uh directly detect uh
chemicals in in the air um there are
ones you know you can get
um particular sensors that will measure
you know carbon dioxide carbon monoxide
dust these kinds of things you can
imagine something where there's a pretty
broad spectrum
sort of chemical etc sensor for things
that are in the gas
around you so to speak um again those
are things where
i don't think we have a tremendously
refined sense
of what we would do with well maybe
something more extreme
than just having a sense of the total
concentration of some particular
chemical that we might smell with our
noses
but if we had an uh something more like
if we had
um stereoscopic vision if we had
multiple sensors
for that that that smell we could tell
oh the smell is coming from this side
it's coming from that side
just as with our eyes we can tell a
bunch of information about
where things are coming from how far
away things are because we're able to
to tell what the difference in the angle
that we're seeing
something from from each of our two eyes
and if something is very close up
then that angle will be a big difference
in angle if the thing is very far away
there'll be a small difference in angle
and that's how we can tell how far away
something is
using our eyes actually we have we use
other clues that are based on
just our experience with things that we
see and sometimes those other clues are
more important
than the specific stereoscopic vision
aspect of what's going on
but uh you know i think this question of
of um uh
what are what are things like when we
have a lot more sensory input as an
interesting one
i mean we can imagine something where we
have
little sensors all over our environment
and somehow we're feeding those sensors
to ourselves maybe through some
augmented reality interface and then
what is it
what is it like when when you're not
just seeing things with your own eyes
but you're you're having all this
information fed to you
uh perhaps um uh perhaps um in in other
ways than just with vision and so on
i mean the the most extreme version of
this that people talk about
is what if we could just directly feed
into our brains
this data so normally what's happening
is we see something with our eyes
the light falls on the retina at the
back of our eyes
the um every every photon of light that
falls on our retina
uh well at least a decent clump of
photons together
will well actually ever every photon
will tend to
uh cause the cells in our retina the
the um the to uh produce a little
electrical signal
and those electrical signals are then
fed through our optic nerve
to our visual cortex which rather in
rather bad design is
the back of our heads and in that visual
cortex
the electrical signal that comes from
that visible that light falling on your
retina
is turned into something which becomes
eventually
an experience for us in fact in the
visual cortex one of the
quite surprising things that was
discovered in the 1960s
is that the the the sort of the map
of the visual scene of things are on the
left things are on the right and so on
is quite literally translated into our
visual cortex there actually
are layers of cells that are laid out
just the same way that our visual scene
is laid out
they go to successive layers and as you
go to higher and higher layers
there's sort of more and more uh
correlation more and more interaction
between cells and different parts of the
visual
scene and so for example in the first
level of cells
a typical thing that will happen is
there will be cells that work out
oh this is an edge because we can see
there's uh there's a bright color here
and there's a dark color sort of one
pixel
one retina pixel away or something from
that one and so
that's a way of sort of detecting an
edge and so for sort of higher levels of
visual processing
all we know is that oh there are these
edges there are these blobs here
we don't know anymore sort of what the
individual pixels are
as we go to higher levels of visual
processing presumably we identify whole
objects and then we can start to
to think in terms of those objects i
mean curiously enough in artificial
neural networks
the um very very much the same
methodology is used
so-called convolutional neural networks
basically are an array
of sort of artificial neurons that are
very much like the array of artificial
neurons that we have
real neurons that we have in our visual
cortex i mean there are there are all
kinds of weird things about our visual
cortex for example
our two eyes um they the the the
information from our two eyes
gets mixed together in the visual cortex
but the sort of first
level of cells have some cells that come
are getting signals from our left eye
some from our right eye and they kind of
interdigitate
um they make a kind of a pattern of left
eye right eyes some cells for the left
eye some cells of the right eye
you kind of make a thing that looks a
bit like zebra stripes where some cells
are getting information from the left
eye some from the right eye
and as the information from the two eyes
are sort of mixed together
that's where we start to get
stereoscopic vision and we start to get
kind of depth information and things
like this
but there's sort of a question if we
were going to feed
new data directly into our brains where
would we put it
because for the thing we have for our
eyes
we have a very definite setup for
in our visual cortex for how the data
from our eyes
gets turned into things that are uh that
we deal with in our brains
so if we say okay let's add a whole
another vision system
where would we what would be the end
point of that vision system where would
it go in the brain
you know we could overlay it on our
usual vision system but we might as well
do that
externally we might as well just show
different things to our eyes
now another question is could we learn
a um a different uh if if we
fed data into some other part of our
brain could we learn
some new form of sensory input my guess
is the answer is probably yes
whether we could do it at all ages i'm
not so sure
like for example in the case of vision
there's a a
a curious um uh thing called amblyopia
which is sometime something kids
sometimes get
but basically what happens is if one of
your eyes has
doesn't have very good vision let's say
you have very you're very nearsighted
you have lots of astigmatism in one eye
or something
but the other eye is just fine then if
that happens when you're when you're
a young kid then your brain will just
say
look i'm getting great visual input from
the good eye
and i'm just going to ignore the bad eye
and so what ends up happening is
that the visual cortex just
just makes connections for the good eye
and doesn't make the connections for the
bad eye
and so so long as you you catch that
before you i don't know six
ten something like that years old it's
pretty easy you just
you know cover the um uh you know you
correct the actual vision defect
of the bad eye you cover the one that um
uh
that was good for some number of hours
per day or whatever
and the brain will somehow start to be
able to
make the connections and see through the
bad eye as well
and the fact that that's possible at
least at young ages
the fact that it's possible to learn to
see so to speak
um is is perhaps an interesting sign of
the fact that it will be possible
to to introduce other kinds of sensory
input and to learn it
now you know it could be you'd have to
learn it when you were a kid i don't
know
i don't know how sort of uh how how
teachable
uh older brains like mine are um i like
to think that it's still possible to
learn lots of kinds of things but
whether it's possible
to learn things at the level of sort of
very low levels
of of of of neural processing i'm not so
sure
i mean it's kind of a little bit like
the question of you're learning certain
kinds of manual skills
that's easier to do that when you're a
kid or
than than later although in many of
these kinds of things like learning
languages
sort of additional knowledge about how
to teach
and how to give feedback about what you
learned how to tell whether you're
speaking with a perfect british american
whatever accent
um is uh uh is something that has
gradually been been discovered
and it makes it possible for sort of
even people who weren't
kind of doing this when they were when
they were kids to be able to
to achieve good results but so
that's sort of a question of if we had
very different kinds of sensory input
how would we feed it if we're feeding it
directly into our brains if we were able
to have sort of a
a fake optic nerve if we were able to
have something which
was a piece of electronics that directly
sends electrical signals to some part of
our brain
and people are experimenting with lots
of kinds of things to do this
um what kind of uh uh what kind of thing
could we learn from that
obviously the the first places this is
well a bunch of places this is happening
but but
uh uh people where where for example
they have
spinal cord injuries and so on and where
where it's interesting to try and just
do
sort of direct electrical connections to
nerves that's a place where these kinds
of things are starting
and they're also attempts to make kind
of artificial retinas
um where where you're actually taking
sort of electronic data and feeding it
to the optic nerve
um rather than having uh that happen
sort of all biologically but uh these
interesting questions i'm not sure we
know there's a lot of things we don't
know about the answers to these
questions
um i would say that uh as we start to
get these different forms of sensory
input
um if that is a possibility for
for us humans getting these different
forms of sensory input
will give us very different views of the
world and that means that for example
our way of describing the world we were
talking about this in the context of
kind of other critters our way of
describing the world might change
completely
so it might be that uh if you were to um
have a conversation with a human
x number of years from now who was all
decked out in all kinds of uh
extra sensory um kind of sensory
apparatus so
to speak that they might be discussing
the uh
the the their experience of the world
and they might be talking about
things which have words which are
completely alien to us now
and where even the description of what
this word means
will be very difficult to give because
it relates to sensory experiences that
we just don't have
so that's a uh that's a kind of a view
of the
uh well it's a it's a it's a somewhat
sobering view of the future
but i think also we have to realize as
we look back there are plenty of
experiences
if we go back let's say 500 years there
are plenty of experiences that
technology has allowed us to have
or in some cases science has allowed us
to have that would be quite hard to
explain um
from 500 years ago just because that's
not kind of the experience of the world
that existed at that time
let's see oh gosh there are all kinds of
questions here
oh so many interesting things um
there's a question here there any
implication of standardizing the
identification
of chemical signatures of odors that's
an interesting question
okay how do we smell well
that's not what do we smell like to
other critters
that's what do we when we smell things
how does that work
it's fairly similar to how we taste
things in both cases
they're very chemical processes like our
tongue has taste buds which are these
complicated
uh complicated cells that little pieces
of food get stuck in
and they essentially are having chemical
reactions in there that
and the chemical it's like
electrochemistry it's like it's like a
little tiny battery-like thing
where the chemical reaction will cause
the um uh the chemical reaction will
cause an electrical signal to be
produced
that goes to nerve cells in our tongue
or in our nose
and those electrical signals correspond
to uh are what are our sense of taste or
our sense of smell
now as a question how many different
kinds of chemical sensors are there
we've got an example in a different
domain
when we are dealing with light and
vision
we know that there are three kinds of
color sensors that
detect the color of things red green and
blue sensors
there's an additional kind of sensor
that is overall light levels so those
are the the three kinds of cone cells
are the three uh color detecting cells
and the rod cells are the black and
white
somewhat more uh able to sense even
lower light levels than the
than the the cone cells for example
they're the kind of overall black and
white
uh light level that the fact that the
cone cells are different from the
uh the rod cells are different from the
cone cells that's why in low light
levels
you can you can still see images of
things but they're kind of black and
white you don't see color
that's because those images are being
detected by the rod cells in your retina
the cone cells don't have enough light
to don't have enough intensity of light
to be active but um in any case
you might wonder whether uh somehow
perhaps
smell and taste work a bit like vision
because in vision we've just got
basically these three kinds of cells
that detect these three sort of
components of color of light
so how does that work for taste and
smell it's not really known
but most likely there are hundreds of
different kinds of
things that are being detected so it's
not
the same kind of thing as oh you can
just have red green blue pixels
on your computer screen and from that
you can by having different intensities
of red green blue
as far as our eyes are concerned it can
be any color we can describe
um for for smell and taste it seems to
be much more diverse
it seems that we'd have to get sort of
several hundred dimensional
um uh uh kind of range of possibilities
to be able to imitate sort of all the
tastes and smells that we
we detect and that's um
uh but you know there's a question of of
cam one
can one sort of parametrize that people
have wondered whether the shapes of
molecules
might have something to do with the with
the way that they smell
actually more so than the shapes of the
molecules kind of the way that the
molecules vibrate around
that those those vibrations and
molecules might be things that are
sort of the critical piece of what
causes molecules
when we smell them so to speak to smell
in a particular way
uh a place where this is much uh
discussed is in the perfume industry
where there's there's great interest in
figuring out can you kind of
just sort of tune the smell of things in
an arbitrary way
one of the things that tends to be the
case is that any given
scent tends to have a very large number
of different kinds of molecules in it
it tends to not just be oh it's one kind
of molecule it tends to be the things
that are sort of
sculpted to be the sense we want to have
are things that are combinations of lots
of kinds of molecules
probably the same thing is true in food
that um sort of the
the the the the pure case of let's just
eat
you know some pure substance that's
that's unlikely to be
something that will be satisfying it's
like let's eat this thing that has this
whole
range of different kinds of uh molecules
that react in different ways without
different taste buds and so on
that seems to be the most satisfying
possibility um
but so so the answer is i i think um
there's there's there's much more to
figure out about some uh kind of the
the the um uh the parameterization
of of sort of uh tastes and smells
and so on a similar kind of area
is the parametrization of texture in in
in visual texture or tactile texture
when we feel things
um to what extent can one sort of say oh
that's a rough surface
that's a furry surface that's a smooth
surface
we've got a whole bunch of different
ways that we describe surfaces and
and in fact if you if you consider our
fingertips for instance
as we so move our fingers across things
where we're detecting certain aspects of
those surfaces and there's a certain
amount that's been discovered even in
quite recent years
about sort of the way that you can think
about
different kinds of uh just a limited
number of attributes
that can characterize the roughness of a
surface
that's about to be something that people
may notice a lot
because there are displays that have
electrical
characteristics that where the the
electrical characteristics of the
display can kind of fake out
what our fingers feel this was a little
bit more popular actually a few years
ago i think it's become less popular
recently
but there were a lot of experiments done
on displays where you could actually you
know
it really is just this flat piece of
glass
but it has electrical properties that
cause it so that when you
rub your fingers on it it feels like
it's furry for example
or it feels like something else now
quite what it's necessarily doing to
your fingers i'm not sure
because that's always an issue of of
when you kind of uh
you know when you're using kind of
electrical mechanisms to sort of
uh fake out um human sensory systems
uh maybe it isn't good for them it's not
clear
i have to say that a personal quirk of
mine that i will admit to which
is um still a little bit unclear
uh what its real story is and i need to
do more experiments on it
but i noticed years ago that when there
started to be
uh rare earth magnets uh very strong
magnets
um that um uh when those started to be
fairly common
i would get them and i would they would
be in things i was using
that when i would touch them my fingers
would start tingling or at least that's
what i believed
and it is certainly possible that
electrochemically things can happen
particularly if the magnets are moving
relative to your finger you can induce
currents in your fingers and so on
and uh it's not completely crazy to
think that that could stimulate
uh sensations and nerves there i have to
say my
my my children at one point did some
some sort of uh
experiments on me and claimed that my my
claim about this was completely false
but
but um uh you know this is one of these
things where you actually have to do the
experiment carefully
to know what's going on and i haven't
done this experiment on myself
but it's sort of a a question of uh to
what extent
uh can one be sensitive to for example
uh
changing magnetic fields and things like
this and to what extent
uh the the actual uh direct
tactile sensation of these things with
these uh
electrical effects um can make
sort of people uh uh sort of perceive
different textures and so on but this
question about textures and
and whether there are limited number of
attributes of textures that are
sufficient
just like there are limited number of
attributes of colors how much red how
much green how much blue
that sort of gives us the full spectrum
of colors that we normally perceive
i mean i do have to say in the in the
world of colors there's a curious
footnote uh that relates to kind of how
different
organisms perceive things the um
uh some we we have these
these cells on our retina that are
sensitive for example to blue light
and those cells what's actually in them
is a protein
uh i guess it's rhodopsin um that is uh
the um uh a protein that has a
particular arrangement of atoms and so
on that has a particular sensitivity
to blue light well different humans are
different
and so different humans will have
slightly different atoms in that uh
in that protein and that means that
they'll be different
they'll be potentially sensitive to
slightly different frequencies of blue
light
and they'll be able what counts for them
as kind of the most intense blue will be
a little bit different from what counts
as the most intense blue for somebody
else
okay so here's the weird footnote so
the the protein that is responsible for
for sensing different colors on the
retina
is produced by the x chromosome
um and uh so you know what's happening
is the x chromosome contains genetic
information in its dna
um so we have 23 chromosomes and and the
well times two and um we have um
uh the um we we've got um
um these chromosomes are
consist of of um oh hundreds of millions
of um of of base pairs of dna
that provide the the program the
specification for how to make proteins
that are going to be used in different
parts of our body so there's a there's a
specification
that happens to be on the x chromosome
for making
the um the protein that's used for
sensing light uh
sensing color on our resonance okay so
this is uh it's on the x chromosome so
the next fact is that all female
uh organisms have two x chromosomes
males have an x chromosome and a y
chromosome females
have two x chromosomes one from one
parent one from the other parent
so that means that in principle a female
of the species so to speak
can have uh two different versions of
the protein
that is sensitive to
is is responsible for sensing color so
that means that
in principle uh women can have
uh two different populations of of color
sensitive cells on the retinas and
actually this this really happens
and you can even uh detect those
different populations and you'll find
that they're sort of
uh that they're kind of they have
different sort of that they
they look a little bit like zebra
stripes actually strangely through
processes very similar to the ones that
happen in the visual cortex
the way that the that the cells from
left and right eyes get mixed together
but you'll get these different kind of
um uh uh
fingers of different term of of cells
that are mostly sensitive
to one particular kind of blue versus
mostly sensitive to
a slightly different kind of blue so
that means that
in principle if you happen to be one of
those lucky females
who got a slightly different version of
these color sensitive cells
from their uh mother versus from their
father
then they'll be able they'll they'll
have parts of their retina that have
have um uh sensitivity to one version of
blue versus another version of blue
so the result of that is that you can
kind of
that that there can be a higher
sensitivity to
ra variations in color that exists
for somebody with the retina that's set
up that way than
for us boring males for example who have
uh only one version
of the x chromosome and so have
necessarily just
one one version of those color sensitive
cells so that's an example of a
rather subtle effect that is sort of a
different sensory perception
that can exist at least in some people
um
let's see oh boy so many interesting
questions here
um there's a question from william
is it the case that uh left-handed
glucose
and right-handed glucose taste the same
uh they don't taste the same to
everybody um
so so what happens is the molecule that
makes some
uh sugar uh it's it's often called
dextrose
dexter in latin means right and
the reason is that the arrangement of
atoms in the molecule
it it's kind of like it's like if you
have your right hand your thumb is
pointing out that way and your fingers
curl around this way
you have your left hand it sort of curls
around the opposite way around
and if you think about uh some of the
atoms in that molecule
being sort of curling around versus
another atom sort of sticking out like
where your thumb is
um though there are two different
versions of
uh many molecules many molecules that
are used in living systems have two
different versions
a left-handed version a right-handed
version well
in all actual living systems
it's all right-handed molecules the
left-handed molecules
aren't there in in actual living systems
but when you make those same
chemicals in a lab you will often get
the same amount of the right-handed
version as the left-handed version
presumably back in the day you know
sometime
four billion years ago three and a half
billion years ago whenever it was the
life first arose on our planet um
presumably
there were both left and right-handed uh
molecules that existed at that time
and somehow the righties won out over
the lefties
and so the whole sort of history of life
on earth is right-hand molecules
there's kind of a theory that uh in in
physics
most things are kind of neutral between
the sort of left and right-handed
variants
there is one uh exception that happens
in radioactive beta decay
and it is just conceivable that things
to do with radioactive beta decay
in the early earth would have tipped the
scale a bit
towards the right-handed molecules and
away from the left-handed molecules
so it wasn't just the right and
left-handed organisms so to speak
duking it out and the right-handed
molecules winning uh through a
historical accident sometime in the
pre-cambrian period
it might have been more to do with the
actual physics of the construction
molecules
but any case there's a question of if
you take left-handed sugar
and you put it in your tongue what does
it taste like and i believe it's the
case that to some people it tastes
bitter and to some people it tastes
sweet
um that that's that's my impression at
least and i'm
i'm trying to remember because i had
some of this oh boy you're asking me to
remember things from a very long time
ago i'm i'm pretty sure
that it tastes bitter to me um but i
might be uh
i might be misremembering that um that's
something i'm that must be from 50 years
ago
that i that i that i tried that
experiment
um i think uh
um
oh as a question from gregory here about
um
you know what are the red green blue for
for smell and taste we don't really know
people often identify
people people draw these diagrams about
you know uh bitter taste versus this
taste versus that taste
but i don't think it's really very clear
what what
what those dimensions should should be
um
there's a question from william here are
the neurons in the brain
uh do they form is saying a spatial
manifold
uh are they are the connections mostly
local or non-local
so so it could be the case uh for
example
in our retinas there are nerve cells and
they those are very locally connected
like a pixel at one position on a retina
has a connection to a pixel a
neighboring pixel
and similarly in the in the in v1 of the
first layer of processing and the visual
cortex
the same thing is true that there's a
there's a kind of a
an array of neurons there and the
neurons have mostly pretty local
connections
that means for example when you're
trying to process a visual image
at the first level of visual processing
you're doing things like detecting edges
where you're saying
is that neighboring pixel very different
in color from
from me or not as you get to to bigger
scales
as you get to try and figure out more
things about images you have to have
information that that crosses over from
one part of the image to a completely
different part of the image and so what
tends to happen is you go
to sort of higher layers in in the
cortex
as you go to higher layers in the
processing system
the connections seem to get less and
less local and in general in the brain
the connections are extremely non-local
i mean it it a particular nerve cell
might have a thousand or ten thousand
connections it has these long
spindly connections that connect to all
kinds of other nerve cells
uh quite far away in the brain um i
don't know
uh like how many centimeters for example
the maximum uh sort of distance that a
nerve cell goes
is but it's it's it's it's it's
certainly millimeters maybe may even be
longer than that
um one thing that's always been
difficult when people try and figure out
what is the wiring diagram for the brain
it's pretty difficult to figure that out
because even if you freeze a brain you
cut it in sections and so on
it's it's full of all of these different
little little things that sort of um
uh uh are connecting one thing to
another these little sort of wires that
are there
and sort of arranging all the layers and
figuring out what wire connects to what
why that's a complicated thing
it's something that's now becoming much
easier through machine learning kinds of
methods and so on
there there has been um a nice kind of
citizen science project of people
people doing some of these connections
by hand and so on um
but it's it's a challenging thing and
when you ask questions like
oh how many nerve cells is the typical
nerve cell in the brain
connected to what's the architecture
those have been surprisingly hard to
answer
i mean one of the things that's a weird
feature of biology
a very common thing to do when you're
dealing with a large arrangement of
biological cells
is you stain the cells and the
the the thing that happens is there's a
method it's called golgi staining for
example
which is this kind of purple uh stain
and if you
if you use this purple stain for some
bizarre reason i'm not sure is
understood even now
it lights up maybe 1 000 cells
and so if you're trying to understand
what you know what this tissue
what's going on in this tissue and you
golgi stain it
then 1 000 cells will turn purple but
then you can kind of see those cells
uh you know if the other cells are sort
of slightly transparent you kind of can
see the outline of those
cells you don't just have a jumbled mess
where all the cells are connected
together
but they're methods like that that have
been used but it's a quite challenging
thing
to sort of pick apart exactly how things
are connected
i mean that the one example of the
nematode
little little tiny worm-like creature um
that has
a few hundred nerve cells out of about
maybe 1700 cells altogether i think
um that one has been completely decoded
and every nematode
has its some uh has its nerve cells
arranged in the same way
um and um uh in that case it's known how
everything is connected to everything
but in us in our human brains the
connections are probably not
definitely not absolutely determined
that they're they're created
as the nerve cells grow and they they
grow protrudences out
and and whether the whether those uh
whether there's actual
uh whether the actual operation of the
brain can affect
the physical arrangement of these
protuberances as opposed to just their
electrical connections
is not completely known right we are
running out of time here
um the uh
there's a question here about what
happens to people with diabetes for the
taste test
it doesn't really diabetes has has
nothing really to do with
uh the the um uh the sensing of
of um uh
uh of well okay the the
uh diabetes is a is a uh disease
associated with the production of
insulin
uh by the pancreas which is uh an
um an enzyme a it's a protein
a rather complicated protein actually
that
is responsible for uh metabolizing
glucose
for using the glucose that's in your
blood um and so
there's there's there's no direct
connection between um
uh the um uh the kind of um your
well in terms of the actual operation of
insulin and so on there's no direct
connection
between your perception of of taste of
sugar or something
and and um uh and whether
your pancreas is producing insulin or
not um
however having said that i i have the
impression
um that people who are used to having to
sense
their blood glucose level which most
people
are not particularly aware of their
blood glucose level
because most people if you don't eat for
a while
um at least if you're like me eventually
you get to the point where you're
kind of starting to feel really spacey
and so on that's typically because your
blood glucose level is going down
you have to eat something to bring it
back up again
if if you have uh diabetes particularly
type 1 diabetes where you're not making
your own insulin
you can have much bigger variations in
blood glucose level
and people get to the point where they
have i think
some some sort of brain level sensing
of that level independent of kind of the
the
small effects that that non-diabetic
people tend to have
now it's also the case in the we were
talking about sort of augmented
sensors for for humans one that's
becoming pretty common
is continuous glucose monitoring for for
diabetes
and so what's happening there is the
normal uh
level of glucose in the blood is kind of
roughly a hundred in some units the
the units for for for um blood glucose
are completely different in the u.s and
in europe
so it's rather confusing but at least in
the u.s scale a hundred is kind of
typical
and if you don't eat for a long time and
it starts going down i don't know i
don't know how like it goes maybe 90s or
something
and if you eat depending on what you eat
you will get this kind of um
uh the blood glucose level will go up
maybe it'll go up 130 150 maybe higher
than that
certain kinds of foods will make it kind
of give you a a a
kind of a pack of sort of a sugar punch
and the thing will go up really quite
high
and then as your pancreas produces
insulin that
will uh will start to be uh will be
metabolized away and that
that glucose high will disappear and
different kinds of foods have different
profiles
of how how quickly the the sort of the
glucose level peaks
and how high it goes and in different
people
even the same food can give very
different profiles i think even
depending on whether you've taken
exercise recently
or other kinds of effects or even time
of day and so on you can
have a different sort of profile of what
how much blood glucose you get
for at a given time for a given food but
one of the things that's
that's happened over the last probably
decade or so is increasingly good
technology
for continuous glucose measurement which
means
you put a little thing on your you
attach a little thing to yourself and it
has a little
microscopic needle that uh that sort of
pokes itself into probably not not
actually into your blood but into into
the kind of interstitial area
um under your skin and um that
uh and in that and that little tiny
needle
is sensing the amount of glucose and
effectively the amount of glucose in
your blood
and so you're able to get kind of
continuous measurement
of the amount of glucose that that you
have in your blood which is a sort of a
an extended sensory thing because most
humans are at best only coarsely
sensitive to their blood glucose level
but with a continuous glucose monitor
you're able to see the precise variation
of glucose level as you eat different
kinds of foods
and um i'm actually kind of curious i
really need to do this at some point
because i'm really curious because i
like collecting data on myself about all
kinds of things it's like what kinds of
foods give me the biggest uh
you know glucose spike most of the time
and so on um
and this is uh but but that's an example
of um uh
of something where um it's
now now uh i it's a really good question
that i don't well yes if you were able
to get
left-handed sugar into your bloodstream
i am pretty sure
that a continuous glucose monitor would
um detect uh
um would say would count the left-handed
sugar along with the right-handed sugar
in the total amount of sugar in your
bloodstream but what left-handed sugar
would do in your blood i'm i'm really
not sure
i mean the way i think continuous
glucose monitors work
is um they're they're essentially uh the
electrical conductivity
of this interstitial fluid is different
depending no it's it's not quite that
it's it's an electrochemical reaction
where where the amount of glucose is
causing more or less
chemical reaction to happen um in
um um yeah i think what happens is
the little tiny micro needle little
catheter um
is kind of sucking fluid up into a
device
and inside the device there are
chemicals which
will react more or less with them
depending on how much glucose there is
in the system
there has been a long time hope that it
will be possible
to have non-invasive glucose monitoring
where you don't have to poke any needles
into anything
um but where you can simply look at the
uh
kind of the the light the properties of
of the light
that's um uh that's being um absorbed
and
and reflected from your blood so for
example if you have a
a fitness watch kind of thing you'll see
underneath that it has this green
usually green flashing sometimes a
little bit yellow flashing
um leds and what those are doing is
they are the the light from those is
is going it goes slightly into your skin
and depending on what um
and your that that light is being
reflected by your blood
and depending on um how much oxygen is
in your blood
um that there will be different amounts
of light
reflected so it's it's like you know
blood is
is bluer when it has less oxygen and
redder when it has more oxygen roughly
and so what's happening is that is
measuring
the amount of of oxygen in your blood
and every time your heart beats
there will be a pulse of oxygenated
blood that goes out through all of your
all of your arteries and capillaries and
so on and
so what's happening is the fitness watch
is detecting that sort of spike
of oxygenated blood coming through and
it's figuring out how often does
oxygenated blood
come through and it's measuring roughly
oh that's happening 60 times a minute or
whatever
whatever else it is when you have a
pulse oximeter
which is measuring your oxygen
saturation
uh spo2 level um that's uh
that's a more sensitive version of the
same technology
where you're basically measuring the
amount of a particular kind of light
you're measuring
uh the amount that comes back at a
particular frequency
um and
that that gives you um
information about the amount of oxygen
in your blood and it might be you know
98
saturated or or you know if you're if
you're not breathing very well 95
or or 90 or whatever saturated
and that's that's coming back that's
detected
by looking at these light levels from
these particular frequencies of light
reflected from from your blood well so
one of the possibilities
is that when there is more or less
glucose
so the thing i just mentioned is about
oxygen in your blood
when there's more or less glucose in
your blood you might have a similar
effect
the effect is more subtle and because
the regular kind of just
how much light is reflected at a certain
frequency i don't think that
varies with glucose level but what does
vary
is a thing called um it's a thing called
roman spectroscopy
what happens is when you have a a
frequency of light
that's causing molecules to kind of
wiggle around and
that those those wigglings around are
different depending on which molecule is
doing the wiggling
so glucose will have a characteristic
way of kind of wiggling around
and so when you when you shine light of
a particular frequency on a glucose
molecule
it will produce a characteristic
collection of um
it will well it's a little bit more
subtle than this actually
the the um uh uh but basically
the way that it that it interacts with
that light will depend on it being a
glucose molecule
rather than a hemoglobin molecule rather
than some other kind of molecule
and so by looking at the detailed
spectrum
of the sort of wigglings around of that
molecule you can tell
what is it is it glucose is something
else and one day it may be possible to
use romance spectroscopy
to detect the levels of hundreds of
different things in your blood
so it may be the case that that sort of
fitness watch of the future
will actually rather than just giving
you your heart rate
will give you um uh a trace of you know
the total amount of glucose and this and
that and the other in your blood
and so you know it's in the in the kind
of uh see what it
what happens when you eat something
it'll probably be the case at some point
in the future
you eat something and you'll be able to
see this whole trace of different kinds
of things
different levels of different kinds of
things in your blood building up
falling off depending on what you eat
which will
be an interesting feedback mechanism
all right i think i have to um
uh wrap up here for
for the day um a lot of really great
questions here which i hope i'll be able
to
start off addressing next time but
um thanks for joining me and
see you in